[Music]
with new releases ranging from gleeful
throwbacks to the golden age of science
fiction to dark dystopian modern day
thrillers
it's a great time to be a sci-fi fan but
which films should you be watching
here are the best sci-fi movies of 2020
so far
extraterrestrial period piece the vast
of night was made of a fraction of the
budget
allocated to some of 2020's best science
fiction movies
but you wouldn't necessarily know it by
watching it the film followed
switchboard operator
fey and radio dj everett two young
adults in the 1950s who sets out to
investigate the source of a strange
frequency
they're both picking up during a quiet
night at work in a small town
writer director andrew paterson pulled
out every trick in the indie film book
to bring his feature film debut to life
creating some beautiful and highly buzz
about tracking shots with nothing more
than a digital camera gimbal and a
go-kart
the whole film was shot in the small new
mexico town of whitney
where the locals were more than willing
to help in fact paterson borrowed the
aforementioned go-kart from a local teen
the vast of night made its festival
debut in 2019
and was quickly snapped up by amazon who
released it on prime in may 2020. in an
interview with the movable fest
patterson spoke of his first film and
said this is something i'm very proud of
everyone that worked on this movie since
it debuted a year ago
has been passionate about it and have
found creative ways to make it relevant
so this movie has done everything i
could have imagined now i really hope it
can become the kind of thing
that people watch for several decades
the film has been reviewed
enthusiastically with critics calling it
a smart
restrained and well-made take on the
classic alien invasion story
easily reaching certified fresh status
on rotten tomatoes
if you're in the mood for a short and
sweet movie that draws you in with
its atmosphere and craftsmanship instead
of just trying to dazzle you with
special effects
the vast of night is definitely worth
your time
parasite star choi wushik plays one of
four desperate young men that pull up a
daring heist in a south korean sci-fi
action thriller
time to hunt the film premiered at the
berlin international film festival in
february 2020
becoming the first korean picture to be
shown in the festival special gala
section
the premiere was followed up with a wide
release on netflix a few months later
set in a future version of south korea
crippled by a financial crash
director yoon sun hyun's dystopian
thriller follows a four protagonist
as they tried to disappear after
sticking up the patrons of an illegal
gambling den
things rapidly descend into violence
when a merciless assassin comes after
the boys
hell bent on retrieving the cash and
cctv hard drives they stole
speaking to the korea times yoon
revealed that the film's grim setting
was actually inspired by a trip to the
americas
saying i remember being shocked by the
hyperinflation in south america
by buying a soft drink at a store i got
a glimpse of slums in the u.s
which allowed me to portray streets full
of graffiti in the film
despite all those real life influences
the final product is distinctly south
korean
however time to hunt to sleek and well
shot from start to finish
and the stylized action never lets up
something the hollywood trades
appreciated
variety said in its review of the film
once the protagonist's plan
goes into action it hardly ever
decelerates and the hollywood reporter
called time to hunt
a tour de force exercise in non-stop
tension
irish director lorgan finnegan sophomore
feature film vavarium
plays on what research suggests is a
very real fear for millennial couples
settling down and having kids when tom
and his girlfriend gemma decide to buy
their first home
they visit a real estate agent who tells
them about yonder a new suburban
development
the couple decides that living among
rows of identical houses
isn't for them long before the creepy
agent vanishes and when they try to
leave they discover that every road
leads back to the house he showed them
number nine again did we just do some
kind of loop things go from weird to
weirder when a mysterious baby turns up
on their doorstep
along with a note that says the couple
won't be released from the bizarre home
until they've raised the child jesse
eisenberg and imogen poots were both
roundly praised for their performances
in the film
which debuted at cans and was released
in march 2020.
at the time vast swaths of people were
isolating in their homes due to the
covet 19 pandemic
and finnegan has admitted that there are
definitely some quote weird parallels
with his movie
he told vulture sometimes i think films
are a bit like
they popped us as if there's a network
between all of humanity
like there's a subconscious thread
that's connecting everything and films
are just a manifestation of these sorts
of anxieties that everybody has the
critics couldn't help but take the
timing of the release into account in
their reviews with vague visages calling
vavarium quote the ideal isolation
horror
a 2020 sci-fi film that took on new
meaning during the pandemic
nisa hardiman's critically acclaimed
feature-length debut sea fever
follows a marine biology student who
buys her way onto a fishing trawler so
she can conduct
research into formal behavioral patterns
her myony core field savannah doesn't
fit in with the vessel's hardy crew
led by dewgrey scott's captain jared but
they turn to the knowledgeable redhead
where mysterious holes appear in the
boat's hull as she's the only one with
diving gear
zavon goes below to check the course and
discovers a gigantic organism with
tendril-like appendages though it's the
parasites the squid-like creature
releases into the water supply that pose
a real threat
straight through the steel sea fever is
essentially
alien on the open water hardyman peso
mates to the film's director ridley
scott
with some squirm inducing body horror
and she creates the same kind of
claustrophobic tension that made aliens
so enthralling
if you've got a thing about eyeballs
maybe swerve this one the director told
quiet dearth that their boat was
positioned quote
days away from shore during the shoot
creating a genuine sense of isolation
among the cast she explained
it's really disturbing being on the boat
because it leads to a kind of collective
agoraphobia
there you are on top of one of the least
understood biospheres on planet earth
we know more about the surface of the
moon than we do about the deep ocean
spanish sci-fi thriller the platform
takes place inside a so-called vertical
self-management center
a tower-like structure that houses
hundreds of inmates
every day a platform filled with enough
food and drink for everyone descends
from the top level
though many routinely go hungry see the
residents are allowed to consume as much
as they'd like
meaning those near the bottom get scraps
of their lucky debuting director
gaudegas teluguritia told the guardian
it's an allegory about the distribution
of wealth which is a universal debate
and a debate that's been going on for as
long as people
have been around the point of the
platform is that it isn't about a war
between those above and those below
we all have someone above us and someone
below us the film follows goring
who's duped into volunteering for a
six-month stint in the tower
in exchange for a diploma being
periodically moved from level to level
he sees the conditions on the lower
levels with his own eyes
and decides to take matters into his own
hands when goring is assigned to level 6
he convinces his cell mate baharet to
ride the platform down with him
distributing russian to portions of food
as they go
the platform's ambiguous ending didn't
turn off the critics who overwhelmingly
enjoyed it
the new york times raved a gnarly mashup
of midnight movie and social commentary
with genre jolts and broad messaging in
equal measure
back in 2017 the mummy was supposed to
be the first film in a new cinematic
universe based on the universal classic
monster films
of the mid-20s through the 1950s but the
so-called dark universe was called off
when the tom cruise led blockbuster
flopped at the box office
the original plan was to have johnny
depp star in the second dark universe
film
though he was dropped from the invisible
man when the studio decided to take a
new approach
not sure i deserve that source lee 1l
was brought in to direct and he was
given the freedom to make a film that
didn't have to include
any links to future franchise
installments the result was a thrilling
stand-alone sci-fi horror flick that
blew the critics away
one else remakes stars elizabeth mars as
cecilia cass
a woman who believes she's being stalked
by her controlling and violent ex
despite the fact that he killed himself
after she escaped from him
this is what he wants this is what he
used to do when we were together he
wants
you to think that i did it this is what
he does cecilia's paranoia leads her
back to the huge house that she shared
with loaded optics engineer adrian
griffin
where her mounting suspicions are
confirmed when she discovers one of
adrian's invisibility suits
before cecilia can prove her story
however her invisible tormentor gets
incredibly violent forcing her to fight
for her life most delivers a typically
committed performance
and she helped out of camera too when al
told gazmondo
elizabeth moss was my greatest asset and
greatest ally
the amount of collaboration that we had
she really became a co-writer in a sense
sonic the hedgehog looks set to join the
long list of terrible video game
adaptations when the first trailer
dropped and fans reacted to the titular
character's design
with a mixture of disappointment and
horror sonic looked far
too realistic making him appear more
creepy than cheeky
twitter to came with the vfx team's
bizarre choices with sonic's human-like
teeth being the biggest offender
but in an unexpected move that
ultimately paid off paramount agreed to
a complete redesign of the eponymous
blue hedgehog the end result was a
charming and entertaining family film
that imagined sonic as an alien who
comes to earth to hide from those
seeking to exploit her super speed
it didn't do much for the average critic
but it was a real hit among sonic fans
director jeff fowler's movie wound up
with a lukewarm rating on the tomato
meter but audience reviewers enjoyed
watching sonic and james marston sheriff
tom wichowski take on jim carrey in his
element of the iconic dr robotnik
one critic who did show some love for
the film was the guardian's keith
stewart
who argued that video game movies aren't
necessarily interested in critical
acclaim
saying they don't really function in the
same way as other big commercial tie-ins
they are multi-layered in a semiotic
rather than emotional or thematic sense
they are fanservice but in a good way
nicolas cage got back to his gonzo best
in colour out of space
a superbly executed pulp heavy sci-fi
based on the hp lovecraft's short story
the colour out of space it was the
author's personal favorite and it also
means a lot to director richard stanley
whose mother was a huge lovecraft fan
i read it when i was 13 years old my
mum introduced me to lovecraft he was my
mother's favorite author
so when the chancellor director big
screen adaptation came stanley decided
to get back in the game and his return
was a critical success
color out of space follows farmer nathan
gardner and his family who were thrown
into a purple tinge nightmare
after a meteorite that's harboring an
extraterrestrial organism lands on their
property
a strange alien colour spreads across
their farmland causing the animals to
mutate and turning the plants sentient
it's a mind-bending experience that only
stanley could have pulled off
according to cage who told slash film of
all the filmmakers i could imagine doing
this and getting close to creating an
alien color
it would be richard check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you